so the town that you hailed from
Kittanning Pennsylvania you go into how
it's a small-town vibe that people say
hi to you on the street even if they
don't know you do they know your family
how was that for you coming to LA where
people are a little more guarded at
first and for good reason
versus going somewhere where people a
little more open how does that culture
shock well let's see small towns yes
everybody knows everybody everybody's
parents know everybody else's parents
sometimes people's grandparents know one
another so everyone knows everyone and
there's a trust if you're doing any type
of business or any type of like
interactions you know nobody can really
betray your screw over because they will
have to answer because they're they're
not gonna move across the country right
there's just there's they're just too
too closely linked so and um so there's
a lot of judgment that comes along with
being in a small town and scrutiny then
of course you go to Los Angeles which is
the entertainment capital of the world
and what at least half of everybody you
meet here has to have escaped a small
town themselves were they to Los Angeles
so they could be themselves
now with that comes the anonymity factor
and you don't know who you can trust or
who you can't trust so putting together
something like our music video was
definitely more challenging than it may
have been like in Pennsylvania where I
knew the parents of everybody I may have
I have wanted to work with but at the
same time you know the talent pool
wouldn't be the same where the the
openness to be creative so I guess
there certainly is a lot of contrast
between small towns and Hollywood
California
so the key might be to try to take
advantage of what Hollywood has to offer
and steer clear of the pitfalls which
there are many we've found out well a
dark side of that small town comfort is
everybody knowing things about you now
that you have the documentary out and
and things are escalating how does that
feel because now it's on a bigger
grander scale that people will know they
can just google your name and find
things out is that okay or because it's
sort of the same type of thing now yeah
well I have to say having made it out to
Los Angeles and finishing the music
video in and of itself was a validation
because it felt like we were facing a
lot of judgement from our peers or our
husbands or our in-laws you know me and
the girls in the band had always been
sort of breaking the mold around town
and and we're perhaps looked down upon
so getting out to Los Angeles and
finishing the music video in and of
itself as a validation but now that
we've actually finished the movie and
they it's we have our story to sort of
bring out there for people to relate to
about what we were going through and in
the process of getting out here
emotionally and what we were what we
were up against and having now the movie
being finished and seeing PR coming out
that's that's good it is such a
validation because that I just hope
everybody from home sees it because
everybody was so critical it just really
felt that way and
you know looking down on us and wanting
to you know put down our creativity so
it's extremely exciting now that the
movies done and we're getting to kind of
like break free and and show everybody
that you really can be an individual and
maybe there's some value in that instead
of just conforming has anyone reached
out to you from back home and applauded
you or I mean do you think people do
that because they themselves want to
live that dream out and they're angry
that they can so they have to stop and
somehow I think so and that definitely
was one of the goals of the movie is
what are you going up against when
you're not conforming to everybody
else's expectations of you and wanting
to encourage other people who might feel
a little bit suppressed or repressed and
the Midwest or you know wherever they
are so we wanted to do that we kind of
felt like okay we're brave enough to do
this we have the chance to do this and
we have sort of a vehicle of this band
but our our main goal was and even as we
met people across the country and now
with the film was reaching out to people
and saying you know what don't make
other people lead your life for you or
don't allow other people to lead your
life for you like go ahead and do what
you want to do we did it you can do it
too that was kind of our message
you